hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video I want
to be going over our weekly ink let's
practice question and don't forget to
check out the other questions in this
series so let's take a look at our
question your patient's blood glucose
level is 215 milligrams per deciliter
the patient is about to eat lunch per
sliding-scale
you administer four units of insulin
list Pro which is Humalog subcutaneously
at 11:30 as the nurse you know the
patient is most at risk for hypoglycemia
at what time
a 1145 B 12:30 C 1430 or D 1630 so the
first thing what we want to do is
analyze our scenario and the first thing
our scenario tells us is the patient's
blood sugar which is 215 milligrams per
deciliter so you should be asking
yourself the following questions what is
a normal blood sugar before meals what
should a person run they should run
anywhere between 70 to 130 milligrams
per deciliter so our patient is high in
their blood glucose and we want to
provide them insulin coverage before
they go and eat their meal because this
is one increase their blood sugar even
more now the physician has ordered
insulin list Pro which is also known as
Humalog okay so think back to those days
in pharmacology what type of insulin is
list Pro also known as Humalog and you
have four different types of categories
of insulin so let's see what it falls
into we have our rapid we have our short
we have our intermediate and long okay
in rapid you have three different types
we have insulin list Pro which is
Humalog which is the one that we're
going to be giving some we know it's
rapid we have a sport which is novel log
and Glu Lezyne which is also called a
Piedra then you have short which are all
your regular insulin so any insulin
name that says like humulin are or novel
and are we know that those are short
acting insulins
then you have the intermediate ones and
these are the ones that are like your
NPH and anytime you see intermediate
insulin in a vial it will always be
cloudy
so if you see cloudy insulin know that
that is an intermediate acting insulin
and this includes like novel and in
humulin in so anything that ends within
then you have your long-acting insulins
which includes Lantis which is also
known as glargine insulin glargine or
leaven mere which is known as detriment
so we've determined that this is a rapid
acting insulin now if you need a
mnemonic to help you remember all these
categories along with their onset peak
and duration because a lot to remember
on top of it the other stuff I have a
video insulin mnemonics that you can
access up here in the card and it will
go over those mnemonics with you so you
can have some memories memory aids to
help you remember this material now our
question wants to know when is
hypoglycemia most likely to occur with
this rapid insulin which is list Pro so
hypoglycemia is whenever the blood sugar
drops so it gets low and insulin works
we have three things we need to remember
about each insulin we need to remember
their onset pink and duration so you
need to ask yourself when will
hypoglycemia occur during the onset
during the peak or during the duration
so let's see what you turbo onset is how
fast this insulin is going to work peak
is when it's the strongest that has the
strongest effect on the body and
duration is how long that insulin is
going to last so when is the patient
most at risk for their blood sugar
dropping deering when it's the strongest
has the strongest ability to get that
blood sugar down which will be its peak
so we need to know what the peak of the
lisp rode this rapid-acting insulin is
now that's where those mnemonics come
into play because there's a lot to
remember with those okay so let's go
over him for this particular category of
insolence remember this mnemonic because
whenever I was in nursing school these
really just gave me a sick because there
are just so many numbers to remember for
each category so I developed these
mnemonics which are nursing specific to
help us remember them because if it's
something that has to do with nursing
we're more likely to remembrance since
we're going to be doing it day in and
day out okay so for specifically the
rapid-acting insulin we have our onset
or peak and duration and this is what
the mnemonic says 15 minutes feels like
an hour during three rapid responses so
this mnemonic tells you several things
it's going to tell you the onset the
peak and the duration in chronological
order and it's gonna tell you which
category of insulin it's for which is
for rapid so the onset it's 15 minutes
the peak of wind it's gonna have the
strongest effect on the body in the most
risk for hypoglycemia isn't our and our
duration is three hours so what time
think about to our question did we give
this insulin we gave it at 11:30 and our
peak is in one hour
so they're most at risk for hypoglycemia
and an hour from that which would be
12:30 and these questions like to throw
things at you like the onset which is 15
minutes well we gave it out of 11:30 so
11:45 that's when the onset would be and
the duration three hours would be 2:30
so always make sure you have these
organized right in your mind so you know
what the questions asking so it doesn't
trick you so this wraps up this review
on this NCLEX question be sure to check
out the other questions in this series
and our other videos such as our ink Lex
lectures